[Music]
welcome to the European Council in
Brussels
we're only few hours away from the next
European Council summit what does that
mean so this is the actual place where
leaders of all EU countries meet in
order to discuss pertinent issues of the
day right now we're at the very special
spot because this is where the journey
of the leaders begins this is the place
where they arrive before they go and
meet the journalists here in Europe a
building
we are in the Europe are building right
now this is where you summits take place
it may look quite calm at the moment but
soon it will be buzzing and bustling
with journalists trying to snap the best
moment of their leaders surviving here
on the red carpet on their way to the
meeting
welcome to the European Council summit
meeting room this is where your leaders
meet to discuss and set the political
agenda at you this is the extra place
for the president of European Council
seats with all the EU leaders apart from
that you can also see interpreters posts
that are all here around this means that
leaders can speak in their own language
[Music]
welcome to the a dream of the council
normally it looks like this
but as you can see right now it has
turned into kind of a extended press
center in order to accommodate hundreds
of journalists that come to cover the
summit from all over the eave
it is here where the president of
European Council and together with the
president of European Commission come to
report on the outcome of the meeting
that's it for the moment we'll be back
soon with some more updates about the
atmosphere and backstage from the summit
in the meantime you can follow life
updates on our social media accounts or
you can dive in more details on
Concilium Europa EU
[Music]